here's a tweet from Joe Biden over the
weekend now Joe Biden obviously does not
tweet himself there is literally zero
chance that they let Joe Biden hold the
phone you can say what you want about
Trump but it was all coming out of trump
but somebody whether it's an intern or
whoever's tweeting for Joe they try to
make it sound like it's Joe they try to
go folksy here and here's what it says
look I think you should be able to be a
billionaire if you can earn it but just
pay your fair share I think you ought to
pay a minimum tax of 25 it's about basic
fairness
guys
I'll get to Elon musk's response in just
a sec but do you see how all he wants is
more money for the machine now first off
billionaires pay crazy amount of taxes
and they pay taxes in multiple Fashions
whether it's income tax or payroll tax
or property tax etc etc they also employ
dozens hundreds thousands of people to
do all sorts of jobs and they often pay
them a lot of money to do it and they
have Yachts built and you might go well
he doesn't need that yacht and first off
it's not your business whether someone
has a yacht or not and also it costs a
lot of money to buy a yacht and then
there's a business of building yachts
and then the yacht guy can hire a whole
bunch of people engineers and people who
are going to be under the yacht fixing
things and all sorts of stuff the guy
who shines the yacht and people then
have jobs and then can pursue their
dreams but you see what Biden and the
Democrats want more than anything else
is that you will always pay more into
the system because if you always pay
more into the system somehow the Biden
family becomes pretty rich the people
who suck off the machine become pretty
rich so Elon Musk saw that Biden tweet
and he had a perfect response I paid 53
percent taxes on my Tesla stock options
40 Federal and 13 state so I must be
lifting the average I also paid more
income tax than anyone ever in the
history of Earth for 2021 and we'll do
that again in 2022 and then he tagged
Community notes that's the fact checking
thing that Twitter is laying out uh is
the three percent number cited above
accurate
look
it doesn't matter you could take all
imagine if you just said okay and this
is by the way what Elizabeth Warren and
some of the really radical nutbag
socialists want to do of the Democrat
Party if you want to tax these people 80
percent
so let's say you took Elon Musk and you
took Jeff Bezos and you took Peter Thiel
and you took 10 other billionaires and
you taxed them at 80 you took virtually
all of their wealth now the government
has all of that money do you honestly
watching this right now sitting there do
you think that anything would be done
better do you think they would do
anything better with that money do you
think anything would be run better or
any problems would be solved of course
not of course not it's the amount of
money that they have that they spend on
all of the wrong things that is the
problem so starve them that is what we
should all be doing
foreign
[Music]